all right who let the cats out my first
question we've talked a lot about dog
shows in the past but we hardly ever
talk about Cat shows that's right and so
cat fancier fanciers Association judges
Gerald Newkirk and Liz Armitage joins us
right now Helen Honey exactly we had a
change of Judges I'm so sorry Ellen I
apologize I apologize
um you're here for the cat
show tell us about this International
show and how is it different from the
the AKC dog show The Kennel Club yep
actually the in the dog shows you enter
your dog and you get one judging there's
one judge for your class of dogs in the
Cat shows we have anywhere between six
and ten judgings so it's like Tim since
we have 10 rings so it's like 10
separate shows okay so we have 44 breeds
that we recognize uh not all the breeds
get entered in the Cat shows but every
every cat that's entered will be judged
by the 10 judges that are there so when
and where is this going to be this is at
the Henderson multi-generation Center
this weekend and the show hours are from
nine to five PM because cats are a
little kind of hard to control so these
guys are actually doing fairly well
although this guy wants to hit the road
now you have a turkey sangora and uh
yeah let's see Nate's cat can we uh can
we get a zoom in and look around yeah
zoomy this is zoomy zoomy right here
zoomy's beautiful tell us about zoomy
age uh four years old four years yep
she competed in the shows and she became
a grand champion and uh so she's done
very well the the turkey sanghoras have
a unique head structure they have a
modified wedge head their profile is
very straight from the tip of the nose
to the top of the brown the ears are
sort of upright beautiful and who am I
holding you're holding a Somali kitten
oh it's so beautiful nervous it's just a
little bit no no no come here it's okay
it's okay come here come here baby come
here oh now you're stuck in the chair
right back well all right that's my
personality yes okay there you go we
hear that at the Cat shows a lot cat on
the loose or they usually say cat out
okay this is a Siamese this me is
basically is a very long tubular body
very long slender legs very long we call
them long slinkies this cat made some
history in our last show season he was
Beth kitten in the whole organization
and that has only happened one other
time in 1968. so this cat is going to be
on display tomorrow
I mean uh Saturday and Sunday okay at
the show and Ellen who are you holding
I'm holding a Bombay
16 years old
[Laughter]
they're black with copper penny eyes
they their origin is they took a Burmese
and braided to a black domestic short
hair because they wanted an all-black
hat wow well they sure got one there
will be several at the show we think
this weekend so can anybody come out to
the show yes absolutely
ask what kind of prize money do you get
for showing cats well it's really not
price money we we award points okay this
coming weekend is the last weekend of
our current show season uh so after the
our central office scores that show
they'll run out of tabulations we have
uh seven contiguous regions here in the
United States we have Japan we have
Europe as region nine and then we have
an international division which covers
all of Asia including China and a few
countries uh in Europe wow come and get
your cat on yeah really Global well
thank you so much and thank you for
bringing your kitty cats and I'm sorry
my kitty didn't like me too much but we
appreciate it we know it's not easily
traveling no thank you very much we
appreciate it yeah we hope to see
everybody's the cat show this weekend
thank you